um obviously throughout the series we've
talked about
just how tall the recovery is he
obviously has just a monster knife
um what do you feel like you guys could
have done better
um is that something that starts early
and taken about rhythm
is that something that lightning could
have done something just kind of how do
you do that
well what what could uh damn better on
kd
uh oh man um
been you you've been around us like a
long time
what do you what do you think let's have
a conversation
uh the first two things that come to
mind is you could have guided him
me personally yes okay
what else was the second the second idea
would be to
double the ball out of his hands
oh man i don't know man just
keep making it tough oh
one of the best quarters to ever play
the game
um it's good it's kind of it's tough
it's awful you know like he he's the
best he's the best player in the world
right now and uh we gotta we gotta beat
him as a team
we gotta guard him as a team we gotta
make him
um make tough shots like tonight uh
and we just gotta keep doing our job and
hopefully like he hopefully is gonna
miss
but we got to keep doing our job we got
to keep guarding him together we got to
keep showing help
keep making me tough keep picking him up
full court
and then there's going to be times in
the game um
and coach double team him i'm gonna
double team but right now
uh we gotta keep containing him as much
as possible but
at the end of the day he's done an
unbelievable job
i said best player in the world best
scorer in the world
we're doing our job it's gonna be nice
that he's gonna do what he did tonight
have fifty and uh
it's gonna be nights that we gonna try
to continue him as much as possible and
give ourselves
ourselves a chance to uh be in the game
and uh be in a position to win the game
uh but uh keep guard them together one
one guy can guard him two guys can guard
we gotta do it as a team
um would you like to be at the head of
that like
there's something we talked about before
like like you're getting over and being
able to do that is that something that
you would want like in games for sure
like
for sure i want to take the challenge
and um
you know obviously everybody's going to
have a chance to garden but
i would love going to game game six
to be able to guard him and if coach
want me to do that
you know i'm ready for